the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're gonna talk about
synchronization how all these different
nodes on the network come to consensus
how they link up so it's sort of
bringing it all together so so far in
these lectures we've talked about
signatures mining and blocks
transactions and scripts and now we're
gonna put it all together okay what how
does this all actually work what do all
these components come together to do and
how does this make you know this cool
money quick recap on signatures that I
think you got the idea from the
homeworks from lectures you have these
public and private keys you know this
key pair where you generate the private
key you distribute the public key the
private key you can sign a message and
anyone can verify given the triple you
know public key message signature group
this is useful for lots of things
providing identity ownership all sorts
of things and it's better than paper
signatures right paper signatures don't
really sign the message they just sort
of sign the paper so if you change some
part of a document the signature still
sort of looks okay maybe you can see you
know you want the paper to not be
tampered but you can sign a blank piece
of paper and then add all this text on
afterwards right you can't do that
with these systems so signatures are
really cool
and they are sort of a necessary thing
for this network to work okay so mining
in blocks I think you sort of got the
idea with the lamp or signatures if
you've looked at the current problem set
it makes a lot of sense you change your
nuts hash a bunch of times while you
change the uncial but sometimes try to
get a low output okay so you get the
idea of mining right you're you're
proving work by repeatedly going through
different nonces trying to find a
certain hash output that there's no
shortcut to you just have to guess and
check and now if you include the
previous data as part of your input to
that hash function you can make a chain
of work and that's what we call a
blockchain I guess
any questions on this so far it's a
basic idea from two lectures ago right
cool okay and a recap of what Neha said
yesterday
there's transactions and scripts not
gonna go into scripts too much yet
because in practice 99% of the scripts
are just checking a public key signature
right you can do all sorts of other
crazy things with the scripts but almost
nobody does yet basically they say okay
I'm sending to a public key cache when I
spend from it I reveal the public key
check that the hash mashes check a
signature in transactions have inputs
and outputs we went over this yesterday
just a sort of real-world numbers this
is how big things are ish so a
transaction ID and index you know to
point to a previous transaction the
transaction ID is 32 bytes the index is
encoded as a 4 byte so 32-bit integer
which is kind of overkill because I
think the most that there's ever the
most outputs there's ever been is like a
thousand or something so you really
don't need it to be able to go up to 4
billion but that's how it is the
signature ends up being about 100 bytes
because you have to provide the public
key which is either 33 or 65 and then
the signature itself is encoded to
something like 70 bytes both of those
things could be much more efficient but
they're not yet and the output is
actually a lot smaller right and now put
the script the main thing is your public
key hash which in Bitcoin is 20 bytes
and then you have those other little op
codes which it adds a few bytes and then
your amount which is so all amounts in
Bitcoin are encoded as 8 byte signed
64-bit integers so you can have like
pretty high precision and that's all
this also overkill since all the
bitcoins ever mined put together in one
you know if you added them all up it's
nowhere near 64 bits right to the 64
it's like 2 to the 40 something I don't
know so
kind of overkill but yeah whatever so
this is ends up being you know for a one
input one output transaction less than
200 bytes okay so that's that's a
message pretty small you can broadcast
it around the network in point to old
outputs time signatures I've put some
scripts in plenty - yeah okay so what do
we do with all these things what is the
mining process so in in the homework
your mining your name right you connect
to the server figure out what the last
block was put your name on put a nonce
and continue to mine that's not super
useful unless you want to like prove
that you're you know hey this is me in
Bitcoin the basic ideas users are making
these transactions transactions are
moving coins from one place to another
from one key to another they make the
transactions they sign them and they
broadcast I'll get in to what broadcast
means so in in the current problem set
there's one server which is not really a
you know robust distributed system as
people may have seen yesterday from
about 1:30 to 3 p.m. when the whole
thing went down in Bitcoin every you
know it's completely peer-to-peer every
node is the same they're all listening
for people connecting in they're all
connecting out to other nodes so broad
can and they broadcast so if someone
sends you a message you'll pass it on to
all the other people so it's called a
gossip network in practice it works ok
it's fairly heavy load on some you know
network traffic but you can you know
make transactions sign them broadcast
them and then someone the miner takes
all these recent transactions that
they've seen and puts them into a block
and then does some work so those
transactions are now confirmed and
people can build the next block so so
the only difference from the current
problem set is instead of putting your
name in you put your you know you can
put your name but you also put all these
messages that you've seen recently and
so you commit to them that way you could
do it by just sticking them all in but
instead there's a bit more advanced way
to do it
you use what's called a block header
so yeah the block header itself is the
message so similar to the problems that
it's that it's the block header that you
need to hash to get a low output value
not the block itself which is kind of
interesting and the headers have a hash
of all the transactions in the block so
you don't just put all the transactions
into one big you know megabyte data
structure hash the whole thing and then
try to get a low output you actually do
some intermediate steps first and what's
interesting is it's actually just the
headers that make a chain not the blocks
themselves so instead of watching you
could call it a header chain
okay so I'll talk about headers the
headers are 80 bytes and they're
actually quite similar to the blocks in
problem set 2 so the main three
components are you've got the previous
hash the Moroka route and the nuts and
so this is like in the problem set right
you start with a previous hash then you
have a you know data that you're
actually committing to and then you have
some data that doesn't have any actual
meaning right just to get the work done
so I can you know to reference if you
look through the work people are doing
right now this is all public the current
problem set there's a previous hash
which is basically the hash of the line
above it and then there's some data
you're committing to in this case
people's usernames and then some you
know non meaningful data here with you
know just random numbers and stuff looks
like so very similar any questions about
this idea yeah so so we use a merkel
root which i think i've talked about
last week monday instead of just
concatenating all the transactions and
hashing them and together you could do
that now actually it would work it
wouldn't make a huge difference but this
is a little nicer if you want to prove
that a transaction was in this block
without giving the whole block right so
the idea is I have these TX IDs and at
exid transaction ID is just a hash of
the transaction take at all you know
stick all the components of the
transaction into bytes hash that and
you've got what's called a TX ID and
that's how you refer to transactions you
know you you hash these two together to
get this intermediate point do the same
thing up to the to the root and so you
can't change any of these little
transaction IDs without changing the
merkel root so it commits to all the
transactions just the same way it would
if you just concatenated them all
together and hash that so it really it
will go in to later why this is useful
but in many cases it really doesn't help
too much ok any questions about Merkel
Merkel tree good ok so the actual
Bitcoin headers which many things use
has a couple fields some of them are
actually not very useful but the main to
our previous Ashe Merkel route notes
right and then there's I'll talk about
the other things so there's also a
version field right at the beginning
it's four bytes
an indicates block version it's not
clear or what that's going to be used
for in the future it used to be used for
sort of signaling protocol changes not
sure that's going to be the case going
forward because didn't really work very
well for that so right now I think they
all start like 0 2 and then a bunch of
zeros and that's the current version
whatever that means and if you mind
something with a different version
everyone will accept it but there will
be like these warnings that show up in
your Bitcoin log
files let's say warning unknown version
you know unknown version detected the
idea is maybe well if the inversion
increases or changes maybe there's some
new rules in this system or new op codes
or new something going on and you're not
aware of it so you might need to upgrade
your software that was the idea anyway
in practice what happens is you'll see
in your logs all the time they like
unknown version detected and it's just
someone just set random numbers in the
version field and it doesn't seem to
mean anything so not super useful
previous hash just like in the problem
set it's the hash of the previous block
32 bytes Merkle root has described a few
slides before hash of all the
transactions in the block time actually
kind of complex I'm not going to go into
the whole thing right here so so far we
haven't really talked about time does
anyone know why we'd want time in these
uh these headers
right right so it makes sense
intuitively that like if someone says
hey I mind this in 1987 it's like what
that seems crazy right or if someone
says I'm you know here's a block it came
out in two thousand forty six like this
doesn't make any sense so intuitively
yeah like you shouldn't accept things
that are like have some crazy date
that's clearly wrong but why why do we
need time at all yeah okay yeah you
could say here's a transaction and I
don't want it to be valid before August
first and so then you'd say if it comes
you know if it goes into a block and
that block has a timestamp before August
first you know consider the block
invalid you could you could also do you
can also do time stamping based just on
block height but what's the mate does
anyone know the main reason to like have
height here yeah competing so the
competing transactions when they get
into they sort of get into a block and
that sort of solves that competition
right so you have two transactions that
both are mutually exclusive well if
they're both in the same Merkle route
and both in the same block then that
block is considered invalid because it's
like hey you've given me a block it's
got two things that can't both exist
here so throw the block away if you find
two blocks that both seem to have you
know that that sort of collide they're
both pointing to the they both got the
same previous hash right so they're both
in the same height we call of the chain
you could say oh well whichever one came
out first right I'll look at the
timestamp and say okay the block that
came out first will be the the valid one
but the problem is this is claimed block
creation right you can put whatever four
bytes you want in there and so you can
always say oh I I just mined it exactly
one second after the previous block it
just took me a while to you know
broadcast it so so you can't really
trust the timestamp to see which came
first
if you could you wouldn't need all this
crazy mining stuff and transactions
themselves could just have a time stamp
and you wouldn't need this whole
structure so that's you know the
fundamental reason you're mining is we
can't trust people to say when they did
something right if you you know you can
always say no this transaction came
first no this came first so the the real
reason for this blockchain is okay we
know which came before what Oh in
practice the time stamps are pretty
unreliable they can be off by minutes it
can be before the previous blocks time
that's okay you know it seems
intuitively like well that should just
be a rule and it probably it would have
been cool if it was a rule and made
things simpler from the beginning but
you know if you you're pointing to a
previous block I'm building on top of it
and that the previous block came out at
you know 10:15 and I set my timestamp to
10 12 3 minutes prior to the previous
block logically that's impossible right
I'm referencing something and I'm saying
I'm coming before it but the software
says that's okay so version maybe you
could get rid of or you could put it
somewhere in the merkel root of
something time actually does have a
really useful purpose does anyone maybe
if you know
yeah so that the really the main reason
for time here is to adjust the
difficulty and that happens every 2016
blocks you just look at okay how long
did this 2016 blaack period take
according to these time stamps and if it
took two weeks okay we're good
the difficulty doesn't have to change if
it took three weeks that means the
blocks are coming out very slowly and we
need to reduce the difficulty if the
blocks if the 2016 blocks came out in
one week
that means wow people were mining really
fast and so we need to increase the
difficulty so there's this feed you know
negative feedback message mechanism
based on this time and it can be tweaked
right it's it's not accurate you can
have things coming in the wrong order
the general rule of thumb and most of
the rule in the software is about two
hours if you see something that's two
hours off from what your internal clock
says you will reject it but that's
that's a huge gap right most most
network systems everyone's you know got
their clocks to the same second at least
or you know millisecond that you know
that that's two hours is like kind of
enormous gaps but the system works okay
because you've got these really
long-term difficulty adjustments that
only happened every 2016 blocks which in
practice is something like two weeks so
if someone's gets something a few
minutes off it doesn't really affect
things too much and it's really only
used for okay look at the last you know
2016 blocks two weeks ish of work of all
these blocks and see you know how fast
we need to make things so that ties into
the next field which is difficulty it's
in a sort of weird floating point like
format with a mantissa and exponent
which is totally custom and you kind of
have to write your own code to deal with
it but it basically says okay what does
the number have to what does the hash
have to be below it's not just number of
bits so in the in the problem set I said
33 bits of work right so that's fairly
easy to detect because you just look for
33 zero bits in the front
in Bitcoin it's not just number of bits
it's actually a number it must be below
if it were just number of bits the
problem then is your adjustments are
fairly coarse because you can only
adjust by a factor of two right you can
double your difficulty or have it but
with this you can have much smaller
difficulty adjustments of like a
fraction of a percent yeah it this field
is is pretty much useless since you can
calculate it from the time fields of the
previous blocks so you could just have
it be implied but it's in there and you
just whatever it some extra four bytes
yeah I don't think you actually like you
could you don't have to store it on a
disk if you want you can because you can
just figure it out from the other things
because you can figure out what
difficulty is just from the headers
right so I mean it's in there I guess
it's nice if you just want to validate
whether a single header has enough work
but it's like how much work does it
claim it needs and then you can validate
it but I don't know it's in there it
doesn't you you could take it out and
reorganize the code a little if you
wanted to optimize it but that would
change so much that no one bothers
right so in this it's just everyone
broadcasts their blocks so if you've
received a block or if you found a block
yourself you just send it to all your
peers that you're connected to and so
there's no like oh this is the canonical
block there can be competing blocks
where you have to at the same time and
just stochastic lis one of them will
pull ahead because you know randomly so
you can have conflicting things yeah and
then the adjustments also everyone
computes the adjustments so just and
this is a very actually very quick
computation because you're just looking
at you're not even looking at 2016
timestamps you're basically just saying
okay if height so height is just what
block number it is right so if you're
right now it's about 500 million right
no sorry five hundred thousand so you
basically in the code just say well if
height modulo 2016 is equal to zero
check the 2006 you know check height -
2016 s block compare the two timestamps
subtract them get a duration and then
compare that duration to two weeks and
then change the difficulty
proportionally so it's actually like
super quick for everyone to compute the
new difficulty and they only do it once
every two weeks and it yeah it's it's
pretty straightforward there are like
weird attacks and stuff and it's kind of
some weird off-by-one errors where
you're I don't remember like it's it's
kind of confusing it's also confusing
because the test network which I haven't
gone into but will use probably next
week or in two weeks
there's a Bitcoin test network which
operates pretty much exactly the same as
Bitcoin except everyone agrees that the
coins are not worth any money what's
interesting is it's actually called test
net three the first to test networks had
the same set up however the agreement
that they were not worth any money broke
down so I had tested that one someone
said hey I'll pay you a Bitcoin
for a million tests net coins and once
people saw this happening they said oh
well you just ruined test net now
they're worth money so we'll go to test
net - it happened again test net threes
had some staying power I think people
realize that if they try to buy testing
at three coins
everyone's gonna leave and go to testing
it for it's kind of a fun I I would I'd
actually be okay with test net three
coins being worth money because I have
many many thousands of them but but yeah
and so so one difference one difference
though between the test networks and the
real network is the difficulty
adjustments so I think in the first test
network it just worked exactly like
Bitcoin but one of the problems was
people would mine and the difficulty was
it would increase and then people would
stop mining you know so oh I'm gonna
test out my mining software okay I'll
mine a couple thousand blocks maybe it
only takes me a day or two to do so
because I have a very you know fast
computer compared to the rest of the
network and then I say okay well it
works cool I'm gonna go to the real
network now and I leave the test network
and now the difficulty increased because
let's say 2000 or 4000 blocks came out
and they came out very quickly so the
difficulty went up and then all the
mining power left
and so now blocks aren't coming out and
since the adjustment can be up or down
but happens based on number of blocks
not based on time if you know if you
have a very high difficulty and block in
the very low hash rate relatives
adaptive to that difficulty it can take
weeks or months or years for the
difficulty to reduce so test net 3 put
in this sort of difficulty nerfing code
which is probably wrong and not what
they intended and it has this thing
where like if twenty minutes have gone
by the difficulty lowers and it's it's
kind of ugly so that's the main place
I've dealt with this field oh one other
rule with the restriction the difficulty
can go up by at most a factor of four
and drop by at most a factor for
so if if you know you mind 2016 blocks
in one day the difficulty goes up for X
but does not go up 14 X or whatever it
you know the implied would be okay any
yeah well sorry not two weeks 2016
blocks which is generally around two
weeks but yeah look at the headers like
this is just the constant you know it
just is always the same so it's kind of
a silly field to be in there you never
need it and it's always the same so yeah
any other questions about yeah oh I'll
get to that right now a couple thousand
four thousand ish I'll get to that I
think but yeah in the merkel route so
the height of the Merkel routes like 12
ish right and it goes out to maybe four
thousand transactions sometimes more
sometimes very few some you'll find
empty blocks I just have no no trying
you know one transaction in them and
that transaction ID just becomes the
Merkel route because a height it's like
a height zero Merkle tree but yeah
something okay and then last pretty easy
there's nuts four bytes anything you
want goes in there you could think of it
as a UN 32 or but it's it's you know
there's no meaning to it okay so does
anyone see a problem with this nonce
field yeah yeah it's too small right
four bytes even even in the homework
people are using 12 something bytes for
a dunce with only four bytes of nuts you
can go through two to the 32
possibilities which is not enough to
mine in in almost all cases because
you're gonna need to go through two to
the 70 possibilities to find a block so
what what are some ideas for how do you
deal with this problem like it would be
nice if it was just a bytes that make
things simpler but the system is what it
is it's very hard to change how as a
minor would you
work around this issue yes you're just
version so that may be why sometimes
weird version numbers come out time is a
good one to since time yeah so yeah
adjust time and also Merkel work so time
it's if you're off by a few seconds
nobody cares
so use the low bits of this time field
as part of your nuts it's kind of in the
wrong place but you can make chips to
sort of fiddle you know twiddle these
bits as well what's also nice is that
every second you can sort of you can you
can do it the wrong way right and you
can say oh I'm just gonna you know take
the lowly significant four bits of my
time field and just use them as a non
space randomly what's nice is that the
actual time progresses by one bit every
second right so as long as you're as
long as your chip has enough space right
so you're like okay I got two to the 32
here another four bits here so I'm not
too to the 36 if your chip only goes
through two to the 36 hashes every
second you're good right because the
actual time progresses the other way you
can do it is modify the merkel route and
you can do that so can you think of ways
to modify that without breaking things
yeah you could add or you could drop a
transaction so you say okay I'm all
these transactions I'm gonna drop one
that's got some disadvantages because it
may pay fees to the minor yep you can
swap them you can just you can just say
okay well these two are independent I'm
gonna swap them this will change which
will change that so you can swap
transactions around you can also edit
what's called the coin base which I
think is in like one more slide yeah but
so yeah so there's a bunch of ways that
you can change things and so this is
really where you're gonna have all the
variation right you have 32-bit bytes
here so and just even if it was just
swapping and if you have thousand
transactions swapping whatever order
there's enough sort of entropy there
that you'll you'll be able to find it
so it's interesting is that the nonce is
there and it's important because that's
where sort of the high-speed mining
occurs but most mining chips will also
have circuitry to modify this because
they're operating so quickly that they
will exhaust the four byte non-space in
a fraction of a second and so they'll
have to you know swap two transactions
recalculate a merkel route which
involves you know a few dozen hashes and
then go back here so it's actually
doesn't hurt their efficiency too much
because okay I just did four billion
hash operations and then I need to do a
few dozen more to get to the next four
billion so it doesn't hurt things too
much also in Bitcoin sort of weird quirk
it's all shot it's it's called sha-256 d
they do shot 256 and then from the
output they do shot 256 again not sure
why I think and what one person's first
problem set they inadvertently we're
doing the same thing and it's like yeah
that works
Satoshi whoever he or she was or they
just put that in there any questions
about this header in this format and
anything about it it's pretty compact
right it's 80 bytes in the block reward
which I'll get to in a second but yeah
you you that's a good question can you
put nothing in as a burglar I don't
think so I'm pretty sure you need one
transaction and there's there's many
blocks so in the first year so in 2009
almost all the blocks are empty and only
have one transaction because no one was
using it but people who are mining so it
was very similar to the problem set
where everyone's just mining and they're
not actually using the system right now
right now get more bitcoins right so you
still get a reward the reason you'll see
empty blocks now is a little tricky it's
I we're not sure right because who knows
but it's probably because of blind
mining where you receive a block and you
haven't actually looked through the
contents of the block yet but you want
to mine the next block but you're not
sure what transactions to put it you
know you see you see this eighty byte
header and you're like oh someone find a
block but you only have the header and
you want to build on top of it because
some you know you have a bunch of
transactions you'd like to put in but
they may have already been put into the
previous one and so you're like well I
have no idea what's in the previous one
I'm just gonna mine a block with nothing
in it that way I'm sure that I'm not
going to conflict with my previous one
so you'll you'll often see it you'll
often see a block with only one
transaction very soon after its its
predecessor block
right right because a minor mite it's
it's actually an optimal strategy for a
minor to say look first thing I'm gonna
do download the aid but eighty byte
header um it figure out if it's got a
valid proof of work if it does I'm gonna
just assume it's valid for the next few
seconds because it probably is and then
I'm going to try to mine a block on top
of that you know reference this previous
block mined a block on top the thing is
I have no idea what's actually in the
block I'd have no idea what contributes
to this Merkle route because I don't
haven't even downloaded that data yet
but I can build on top of it just from
the header but I can't include
transactions because I have no idea what
transactions are in here so they might
conflict so I'll just mine sort of blind
for a second or two and then I download
all this to download all the
transactions validate it and now I can
include my transactions that haven't
been included and so that that happens
it can be an okay strategy sometimes it
can lead to you mining an invalid block
right if someone produces an invalid
block and you just see oh well it's got
proof of work you grab that header start
mining on top of it no matter what you
mind it's gonna be invalid right because
it's pointing to an invalid block that
happened twenty fifteen or sixteen in
the summer of 2015 it happened and it
was like quite extensive it was like
seven or eight blocks in a row they were
all invalid because none of the miners
were actually verifying anything they
were just downloading the headers from
each other and being like yeah I mean he
did the work so they were just assuming
everyone else was verifying the Merkle
routes and yeah so then it ended you
know so they lost twenty five times
eight however many Bitcoin you know they
will last you know hundreds of bitcoins
which at the time was it was still worth
quite a bit and I was worth you know
millions of dollars just because they
weren't actually checking things
why decrease my chances of being mine no
actually I would say you didn't sort of
game theoretically you would increase it
because you're not depleting the mempool
which okay I need to talk about the
actual mining coin base and then pool
and stuff but yeah it's a tricky
question I'll try to get back to it if I
don't bug me again okay TX sew in this
merkel root right you've got all these
transactions they have a specified order
transaction 0 is the coinbase
transaction and it's special it
generates new coins and it takes fees
from all the other transactions in the
block I think may I mention this
yesterday where if you have a difference
between the input amounts and output
amounts that's implicitly a fee right so
if your inputs right so here they have
thing you're spending 20 coins you've
got five ten four okay well there's only
nine coins are 19 coins in the output so
there's an implicit fee of one coin that
that one coin can go to transactions 0
right so transaction 0 has essentially
Note has no input transaction zeros
input field is just empty anything you
want to put any bites you want to put in
there its output field generates new
coins so that's currently 12 and 1/2
coins so currently if you mine a block
with one trend you know only one only
tx0 you get 12 and 1/2 points if you
mine a block with thousands of
transactions you get the 12 and a half
points plus the difference between the
input and outputs of all the other
transactions in the block which can be
even more than 12 a night which can
recently like in January December there
were quite a few blocks where they're
getting 25 26 27 coins because the total
fees for the entire block were more than
12 and half coins which is you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars now so
it's kind of cool the fees have in sense
decreased these are highly variable and
we'll talk about fees in a few more
lectures and it's kind of a medicine
it's but it's an evolving area in this
whole network thing so you've got your
your coding based transaction that's
important that's why people are doing
this stuff
because they want money all the other
transactions can be shuffled around
however they can only spend outputs from
previous transactions and previous means
they have an index within the block
that's lower right so for example you
have transaction B spends an output of
transaction a transaction a must come
first in the block ordering right this
makes it so that you can go through in a
linear fashion and validate every
transaction in order otherwise you'd say
you you know go through C okay
transaction zero I don't have to
validate that that's clean base
transaction one in transaction two and
then you see transaction three it
appears to be spending something you've
never heard of
so that would at first you know that
would appear to be invalid and then
maybe you go through the another few
transactions say oh this creates the the
output that this thing I just saw before
spends it's sort of out of order it
makes things very complicated to
validate and so this rule ensures that
if you go through and just check every
transaction in order it'll all make
sense yes in the walk not no I don't
think so I mean I can't think of yeah I
mean it's just sort of random a lot of
times they'll organize it by fee rate or
by default they'll just organize it by
when they saw them first so it's pretty
pretty arbitrary
no although if they did that would make
the software a lot simpler and easier to
deal with but that is not how it works
right so you can have so for example Oh
dry you can have a block where there's
you know let's do it this way so you
have TX 0
there's coinbase transaction transaction
one transaction two transaction three
and transaction three maybe spending
something that was generated in
transaction one that can happen right so
if you if you make transaction one
broadcast it it son confirmed you then
make transaction three broadcast it
spends transaction one the miner can put
those in the blocks they must put it in
order right so if this happens you can't
switch them in order but that's that's
considered okay it makes parallel you
know it makes multi-core validation more
annoying right if you if you said no you
can only use outputs that have already
been confirmed then the block validation
becomes embarrassingly parallel because
you can just validate every transaction
independently that would be kind of nice
there's there's other interesting
reasons why this is also useful so I
mean if I were designing it I would say
you have to do confirm because it just
makes things simpler but I was not
Satoshi see how the orders fairly
arbitrary any other questions about
block ordering Mirko route stuff and
then we're gonna have a quick
intermission right at the halfway point
sounds good
okay so 256 second break okay so now
I'll talk about the synchronization
process how does this actually work in
the software when you download Bitcoin
so first you download Bitcoin you go to
Bitcoin org some your friend hands you a
USB Drive and says hey I got some good
stuff man it's new thing called Bitcoin
and so you've got the Bitcoin exe file
or dmg file or the binary or the code
and you want to know what's been going
on for the last nine years so first you
download the binary or you compile the
code and you Vera
by all the GPG signatures of this code
right you want to do this securely so
I'm sure everyone has their PGP keys on
the MIT PGP server and goes to key
signing parties held in the weekends
right yeah no key base is also useful
yeah so I have my I have my GP key hash
on my business card I don't think
anyone's actually ever used it but the
Bitcoin nerds actually do do this and
they're very like sort of annoying about
it because a really good attack vector
is to get someone to download
compromised Bitcoin code it's like the
best attack vector ever if you're trying
to you know do something sneaky mainly
just steal are the money if you get them
to download a Bitcoin binary that you
control that you put some back to our
code in you know the code could be like
two lines it's like you know open a TCP
connection to my computer send me well
you know send me all the private keys
we're good or or you know if you want to
be more sophisticated every time they
click send and like you type in their
password I just change all the addresses
and all the outputs to me and like every
time they try to send money the UI sort
of shows that they're sending money but
actually just sends to me and they won't
find out for a little while or you know
there's there's a lot of things where
you want to be running the right Bitcoin
code and that's a hard problem right
because we're sort of operating in this
trust list decentralized network how do
you get into this in the beginning right
if it's your friend and saying hey
here's the Bitcoin I'm running I know
this is good then it works but just a
website what if someone hacks the
website things like that so there's all
it's like a huge rabbit hole and you can
try to worry about it for years but
anyway you download the binary assume
you've somehow gotten the binary in
you're pretty sure it's the right
software so how do you connect to this
network well there are these hard-coded
DNS seeds in order to find peers in the
beginning if you know how DNS works it's
how you look up IP addresses based on a
hostname there are some servers that
will return multiple different IP
addresses every time you query them
and that those are IP addresses of
currently running Bitcoin notes so the
idea is okay someone's running a Bitcoin
node they've got their DNS server you
query that DNS DNS server and it will
hand you out some IP addresses this is
you know also sort of centralized slash
trusted slash whatever in that you know
if someone compromises these four or
five DNS servers you might not be able
to connect to the Bitcoin network right
so in practice it's not completely
mathematically secure and trustless
there's all these real world issues
that's like how do I know I've got the
right software how do I know I'm
connecting to the actual Bitcoin network
what if my ISP is blocking me and
sending me to some other network things
like that so in practice it sort of
works okay right now connect to the DNS
seeds and then you connect to a Bitcoin
node and you ask for headers you say hey
I just showed up I know about one header
there's a hard-coded header in the code
called the Genesis block that's the
toshi did and you say hey I've got this
Genesis block do you know anything that
that you know builds above this Genesis
block that comes after and you say and
they say yes I actually know five
hundred thousand headers that come after
it and they'll start sending it to you
and they send it to you in like a couple
thousand of you know headers at a time
and then you started download all those
and verify that the header chain you get
it first and it's actually very quick
you can do it under a minute if you have
a good internet connection and you
verify all the work before you do
anything else so this is nice and that
the attacker in order to sort of make
you do more work here would have to do a
lot of proof of work but for you it's
very quick to verify everything even
though even half a million headers you
know 30 seconds if you got a good
internet connection something like that
because all you're doing is one hash per
header right you just download the
header check the bits check the time
make sure the times are like you know R
you know progressing reasonably if the
times keep going backwards for like I
think it's ten blocks then you consider
it invalid but your computer can
actually do this you know it's 500,000
hash function
I'm sure if you've seen for the problems
that you can do that in a few seconds in
many cases so you can verify the work
done throughout the entirety of the
Bitcoin existence pretty quickly so then
you've got five hundred thousand headers
and now you need to actually download
the blocks ok any questions about header
synchronization seems pretty straight
right yeah well yeah you save it to disk
so you don't have to like if you turn
your you know if you shut your computer
off to turn it on the next time you've
already got all those headers on disk
basically you save them to disk once
you've verified them so you download a
couple thousand it you know builds
linearly so it's nice you like download
them validate and as you validate write
them to disk and then when you start
back up there on disk you you know you
trust your own disk if someone goes in
and modifies things on disk between
running of Bitcoin all bets are off
right so you sort of implicitly trust
that ok so yeah that's pretty quick
works well then you get to the real hard
part where you know have to validate all
these signatures and download all these
transactions any other questions good ok
okay so then it's called IBD initial
block download so you get the headers
first that's quick now you start asking
your peers hey here's this header from
2009 you know blah blah height one give
it you know here's the header can you
give me the full block with you know
what's in the you know I have the header
what are all the things that go into the
merkel route so you request blocks from
peers you match the transaction list the
Merkel route and header and you process
each transaction in order right so you
download it say okay here's all these
transactions let me take the hash of all
of them compute the Merkel route make
sure it matches the Merkel route I see
in the header if I I've already gotten
and now process each transaction ok so
what do we do to process transactions
okay so you've got this UTX ODB so this
is unspent transaction output so all the
you know I'm sure in like 2030 there
will be a new
where we'll just call money UTX I was
like hey you got I got a lot of UTX out
I mean I'm already doing that and I'm
pretty ahead of the time so so you've
got this database which is basically a
key value store and it just has
transaction ID index right so this sort
of what how you reference inputs in
Bitcoin right the transaction ID index
as the key and then the value is just
the the output write the script sig and
eight byte amount right so there it's
pretty compact you've got all these key
values in it's using a level DB but you
can use some other key value store
database and the idea is okay every time
you get a transaction validate all the
inputs you know make sure all the
signature is good make sure it's
spending things that actually exist in
your you TXO set and delete those inputs
from your UT XE o DB you're saying okay
this transaction is spending these
inputs so delete so Vegas sorry first
make sure the transactions valid given
your current UT x o DB right so validate
that all these inputs exist validate all
the signatures are correct then you're
saying okay this transaction is good now
I modify my database by deleting all the
inputs that are consumed and adding all
these new outputs for the transaction
right so this modifies the database in
place and you sort of all constantly you
know reading from it to validate inputs
and then writing to it to delete inputs
and then writing to it again to add
outputs so it's not it doesn't seem too
bad but there's a lot of disk access and
the UT XO DB is a key value store with a
lot of keys the values are very small so
it's a it's not like a crazy database
problem if anyone's interested in
databases and stuff but you know it can
be slow and we want to really optimize
it so when you sync the initial block
download you're doing this 300 million
times so there's about 300 million
transactions historically so you're
validating signature deleting input
adding output three in a million times
it ends up being about a hundred and
seventy gigabytes of downloads and then
the end result when you're done you know
modifying this database is that you have
fifty five million transaction outputs
remaining and it's about 3.2 gigabytes
of disk skews so yeah but you had to
download that hundred 70 gigabytes to
get to the three 2.2 gigabyte end state
right because most of the transactions
that have been created and most of the
outputs have then later been spent right
so there's a lot of churn so yeah of the
300 million and these sorry these are
not the same numbers I was actually
looking how many transaction outputs
have been created throughout all of
Bitcoin and I couldn't find the number
and I didn't want to you know write
software to figure it out but you know
certainly you can certainly figure it
out from the the blockchain but yeah
this is transaction outputs how many
total transactions have been have TXO as
I'm not sure but yeah so it's pretty big
but it's reasonable right like we can do
this on today's computers if you've got
a decent laptop this is possible this
total time taken depends on a lot of
factors has anyone actually done initial
block download and sync to Bitcoin node
and like want to say about how quickly
they deter okay James how long did it
take
on a spinning festival because I run Oh
point 15.1 on a laptop with a spinning
disc and it'll take like overnight to
just sync up a week or so okay so eight
hours to do the whole thing
anyone else have have tried it yeah yeah
wow that took weeks Oh
so the the software has been improved
quite a bit so if you downloaded it like
I first downloaded it in 2011 and it
took overnight to download everything
and the download was vastly smaller it
was less than a gigabyte to download the
entire blockchain so what's interesting
is that the time taken for initial block
download over the last seven years has
been somewhat constant in that the the
blockchain gets bigger and bigger but
there's all these optimizations to the
code and the databases and so that sort
of keeps pace although actually I'd say
recently it's it's gotten faster because
like 0.5 teen weight Oh point alert 11
or 12 had a big speed up as well yeah so
quarry fields who also works with the
DCI helped to you know refactor the code
make it a lot faster there's still
definitely still optimizations a lot of
cool you know a lot of it's pretty low
level like tweaks kind of stuff but some
of them are pretty big things that most
of the big things low-hanging fruit has
already been got the worry is that long
term this this just keeps going up right
as the blockchain gets bigger and longer
it's gonna take heart it's gonna be
harder to validate it can be
parallelized to some extent but there's
also like network i/o concerns things
like that so it's tricky but doable ok
any questions about initial block
download good ok so here's a question
you've got this utx ODB what about this
hundred 70 gigabytes do you have to
store it or can
you delete it this you can't delete
right so do you think this is okay like
you know yeah you can delete some of
this actually there's a lot of research
into maybe we can delete this
accumulators cool stuff like that it
would be really cool to have some kind
of data structure where we can keep
adding these you know we can add remove
and prove that some things in and you
know seek and see if something's in
there where it either is like constant
size or LOGIN size or something like
that that'll be really cool
there are constructions like that but
they don't work for what we're trying to
do right now but there's a lot of
research into that if anyone here finds
some cool data structure that you can
use for the DxO DB that doesn't keep
growing you know linear size of the
number of keys everyone a Bitcoin will
sing your praises forever so but it's a
active research area
okay so pruning by default oh sorry
the there's only 500 K blocks not 500 am
anyway um by default your your client
will download all these blocks and store
them on the disk and that's important
because what if someone else requests
them from you you know someone else
everyone you know everyone starts out as
a noob someone else comes and says hey
guys I just downloaded a Bitcoin what's
gone you know what's going on for the
last nine years and you might want to
give them blocks to let them into the
system so you can serve to others who
are doing IBD however if you want and
your hard drive small area of an SSD or
something you can prune and delete the
blocks after you've done IBD with no
loss of security right anyone think of
downsides doing so not really right the
only I mean the real downside is sort of
this right Oh
not everyone can prune right if everyone
prunes no new entrants to the system so
it's a little bit of a tricky sort of
like seed versus leech kind of problem
where someone's got to be there to serve
up these blocks you don't have to
trust them right you're still you're
still validating all the work validating
all the signatures they can't do
anything bad
but someone's got to be there to provide
the network capacity and so it is tricky
like most of the nodes on the network
are behind people's you know cable modem
firewall kind of thing so you can't
actually connect to them and download
and if you run a node that does allow
people to connect in and serve them
blocks people will download quite a bit
so I had I have one in the office over
there it ends up upload you know sending
out about three terabytes a month which
is a lot right like it's you know dozens
of gigabytes a day so yeah people people
are doing this people are connecting in
and downloading all the blocks either
through IBD or just keeping up with
current transactions so yeah pruning is
possible but it's someone you know not
everyone can do it so it's sort of an
unsolved issue there there's a lot of
research into how we can do partial
pruning where okay I'm gonna only store
the last month's worth of blocks which
is mostly what people do because a lot
of people have intermittent connectivity
where they'll turn off their their node
and then start it back up again a few
days later and they just need to catch
up with the last few blocks
okay so pruning school that's been
incense Oh point twelve or something so
I'll go through in practice if you go to
you know your Bitcoin node what is
actually store and if you just go to
your Bitcoin folder which in in UNIX
type OSS is like home directory slash
dot Bitcoin total random aside I I don't
like how they put a dot in front of all
the really important folders right it's
like they hide all the important things
like your GPG folders it's got a dot and
your bitcoin folders got a dot but like
downloads doesn't and like anyway so if
you just you know LS in your folder
here's all the files and just go through
real quick here's the files and also
described so there's a band list dot dot
this is a list of IP addresses that you
have banned because they're bad they're
doing something where so I'll get to at
the end I I sort of
of making a band list for the problem
set because there are some knows that
are doing non good things other that was
what caused yesterday's outage someone
was connecting although it was really my
fault because the the server code was
not verifying inputs correctly but yeah
in Bitcoin you verify everything if
people start sending you nonsense data
or they say hey here's a block and it's
wrong or hey here's the transaction and
it the signatures are wrong you'll
you'll pretty quickly ban them because
it's like well if they're making a
mistake you know it's a computer there's
no excuse for making a mistake right so
either their software's just different
than mine or something's wrong with
their software or their hardware I don't
know but they're wasting my time they're
sending me nonsense
BAM so you have your own band list then
these the blue ones are folders I'll
talk about those later then you have
peers docked at which is good notes so
it's quite a bit four megabytes and you
keep track of here's all the different
nodes I've connected to for the past you
know the duration of my however long
I've been using Bitcoin I keep track of
all their IP addresses how how much
uptime they've had what I've downloaded
from them and so you know I sort of sort
them and put the good ones at the top
and like okay here's all the different
Bitcoin nodes so the next time I start
up Bitcoin I'm gonna try to connect to
them so this makes the network very
robust because everyone remembers
everyone else and then when they need to
you know if there's a network disruption
maybe half the nodes go off the network
you can still try to connect all the
rest and then and also peers will share
their peers files not directly but
they'll sort of take random samplings of
this file and share it with each other
so that everyone sort of knows about
everyone else okay
then there's a wallet dot that which is
very important if that's got all your
precious UTX those and we'll talk about
wallets one day there's a Bitcoin conf
little config file you can set some
settings and things like that
debug file which shows all these weird
messages and a memo about that
so the mempool is transaction you've
seen that you've not seen in a block yet
right so people are broadcasting
transactions and you store them
it used to be just in memory hence the
word mempool now it's more like this
cool because you actually store them on
disk because it saves a little speed
when you shut down and start up again
okay so any questions about just what
all these files are doing okay make
sense so now the folders chained state
blocks and database so any guesses on to
how big these things are based on
previous slides or so how big is chain
State for example yes we gave ok ok yeah
three gigs right this is the UT exocet
3ish gigs this is all the blocks what
and then database actually I have no
idea
does anyone know what that is there's a
database folder and it's got one little
log file and it's like 80 kilobytes I
don't know what it is do you guys know
okay yeah but there's a blocks folder
and that's got all the blocks and that's
your you know huge amount of data and
this is the UT Exocet not too bad so
yeah you can you can look in it it's
reasonable but yeah it's kind of it okay
and now so any questions about the data
stuff I'm gonna go into blockchain as a
database real quick at the end okay so
it's 186 gigabytes or alternatively you
can think of it as just three gigabytes
but it's a really crummy database so
I've heard a lot that you know
blockchain is gonna change the world and
it's like a database that's shared among
everyone and you can query things it's a
really bad database so for example I'm
gonna have some like uh fun interactive
questions where as these some of these
are answerable some of these are not so
for you know and I'm posing the question
to my Bitcoin node so I post this
question to my Bitcoin node hey remember
transaction 99 5c3 did it from back in
2014 and how do you think the Bitcoin
node will answer will it answer or will
it not be able to any ideas yeah
uh 183 plus three so the total data
usage on this computers under day six
gigs right the rest are kind of small so
I mean like when you're using Bitcoin
you've got 186 gigs on your hard drive
or your SSD devoted to Bitcoin right so
it's so you've got this 186 gigabyte
database essentially but it's a really
crummy database and it can't do a lot of
the things you might expect it to so for
example this you you arbitrary
transaction from the past you say hey
there was this transaction a couple
years ago give me the information about
it and what do you think the response
from the full node is what's right it's
valid or not valid
any other ideas sorry it asks instead
for a header okay there it is yeah so
sort of that it'll say remember TX this
no it's somewhere in the blocks maybe
but I have no idea where it's not on the
chain State right so the blocks it just
stores the blocks right like here's
block it you know here's this block
here's that block in inline and if you
say hey there's this transaction okay go
look for it
Oh 2014 well that might be somewhere in
the middle but yeah if you don't know
what block it's in forget it so it does
have an index of blocks it'll tell you a
block but transaction no luck yeah he
won't even tell you this exists it has
no idea I might be I might have made
that up right so if you're saying hey
here's this transaction do you remember
it does it exist
yes and uh yeah good question but I'll
get to that
I think but yes if you create a base on
a block hash then it does have that in
the database and it'll be able to get it
for you James you know the database
director does okay I didn't cool it's
very small so I guess it helps things
work okay so this one you do you know
this transaction no how about this well
I've got this output right it's still
there in the UTX like you know I spent
someone spent here it's like this is a
transaction and the first one it's an
opera turn output right so it's got some
extra data but opera turn means it's
invalid I can't spend it can you tell me
what the data is do you think it'll be
able to write if you query hey here's
this output what do you think the
response will be yay nay okay I'm seeing
this yeah
nope if it's not returned output even
though it's unspent well it's unspent
able so the you don't put it in you TXO
database because you just see oh this
output up returns in there don't bother
putting it in no one will ever be able
to spend it so there's no reason to put
it in so opera turns are used to sort of
commit to data all these different
protocols but the actual normal code
won't store them okay anything else next
one this is one hey I have a public key
and here's the hash of my public key is
this essentially an address so we didn't
talk about addresses but the Bitcoin
addresses that start with like a1 and
then have these alphanumeric stuff it's
just a different encoding slightly
shorter than hexadecimal for a pub key
hash so you say hey I've got this you
know I have a private key
I just computed the public key I hashed
it I got this do I have any money I
think I did I don't remember but I
remember my private key I back that up
that was the important part right
everyone says you know keep your private
keys so I have my private key but all
this you know data and all this
blockchain stuff
I lost my computer but how am i private
got my money how many coins do I have
how many outputs what do you think the
full note will tell you yeah
any ideas they'll say I don't know well
you're gonna have to search through
everything in chain State and it doesn't
index based on the public key script
only the transaction ID index right it's
a key value store and the key is this 36
by exid Index so this is this is a very
real problem right like okay I backed up
my key all right I took my private keys
to some other computer or something like
that and this is fairly it's gotten a
lot faster it used to take hours right
where you had a hard drive and you're
like okay import a key to this wallet
and it's like well when did you do
transactions has to look through the
entire blockchain see Tinley I'm
linearly to see if any of these
transactions have an output that matches
that and then says oh yeah you got money
back in 2013
oh then you spent it or then you know
and sort of replays things because it
doesn't have an address index okay next
one this is an example how many coins so
you say hey here's this output this
transaction : one how many coins does it
have will the full node be able to tell
you this seeing about your nays know it
will yeah this is this is the one thing
it can do so if you say hey seven four
three four then another : one it'll know
that that's in the you txt ODB because
that's that's the key that the utx ODB
sorts by right yep this is it this is
aut EXO it's unspent and it has a bunch
of coins and this is fairly recent I was
just looking through someone got yes the
new tax offset hasn't been spent and you
can sort quickly based on exid index
pair right so we said I think this is
some software called an out point where
it's like you concatenate them in this
32 it ends up being 36 bytes right this
is 32 bytes this is 4 so you sort of
have a 36 bytes out point which
describes what goes into the exit
it's very funny
yeah once this is spent you delete it
from the you tick so and you won't
remember it anymore
it'll just be hey do you know how many
coins is happy like well well you can
you can still answer it you say none
right if it's if it's spent and you say
how many coins does this guy have none
it's not in the EXO set which was yeah
so the previous one I just copy these
randomly okay okay so any questions
about what is stored and what is not
stored weight basically keeps track of
ut EXO's and it keeps track of historic
blocks in order to give them to people
and it keeps that to the header so the
headers ends up being small all the
headers total is like what 40 Meg's
something like that so yeah you can and
further indices right you you could
write software to answer all these
questions very quickly but that's not
what Bitcoin does by default those types
of indices would take a lot of extra
space and and add a lot of CPU or things
like that so a very common thing is an
address index so people can ask if they
have any money so that last the the
second the last one where you say hey I
have this key you know key hash do I
have any money do I have any
transactions having an address index is
actually pretty useful for a lot of
things for example importing keys or
like web wallet kind of things but
Bitcoin by default doesn't do it because
well why I mean you can make arguments
that it'll be actually useful to have in
the normal code but we don't okay any
other questions about what indices what
it can do what it cannot do somewhat
counterintuitive in many cases where you
say hey here's this transaction and you
can't actually find it or you have to
scan through 180 gigabytes in order to
find it yeah so with James I have a
question so how big is an address index
for you
Wow so give me hundreds of gigs yeah we
used to generate okay well that's I mean
so the other thing is these these are
like fairly involved sort of CSC
software engineering problems and
optimization really works right if you
download like Bitcoin 0.9 it'll still
work but you're never gonna catch up
maybe not never I don't know if you have
a fast computer but it'll take you know
months and months and as people have
been updating the software and making it
faster making it more efficient now it's
quite fast and you can you know sink
from the holes you think the whole thing
in a few hours on a good computer so so
address index is one of those things
where it hasn't had like the full force
of all these Bitcoin protocol coder
people on it because it's sort of seen
it's like well yeah that's kind of a fun
feature if you want but it's not like a
core utilities okay so yeah maybe you
know it is a database maybe not the best
way to think of it though as don't think
of the blockchain as like a global
shared database because it sort of is
but it's a fairly specific database that
isn't useful for many other things yeah
and it's also untrusted another part of
why is it's untrusted right most of
these things exist so that they can be
used over the peer-to-peer network right
if you request a block I'll give it to
you if you give me a transaction I'll
match it against my UT Exocet but an
address index doesn't work that way it
sort of trusted I can easily omit things
right if you say hey I've got a key what
are the transactions involved with this
key I can admit things very easily and
there's no way for you to prove it
you know or verify it so your DV queries
aren't really given out to network peers
and that works peers are scary and you
need to ban them if they act funny and
this happens all the time if you look
through Bitcoin logs and you have a node
that's up every few seconds you're gonna
be disconnecting from someone or banning
them because they're doing something
crazy trying to hack into you or so
basically all you're doing is you're
providing headers
blocks transactions and you're sharing
the other IPS of notes you try to
simplify okay other questions yeah bad
database good for consensus kind of
works
everyone's got the same UT Exocet even
though they all really would like to
change that UT Exocet I would much
rather everyone had a UT Exocet where I
had those 273 coin use EXO so almost
everyone in the systems would rather
there was a different UT Exocet and yet
they all managed to agree on a single UT
Exocet so pretty cool